okay so
actually it's interesting to break apart
the three moments you mentioned
if it's okay so it'll uh uh i always
have trouble pronouncing his name but
allows yakowski yeah
so what how did your
world view change in starting to
consider
the the exponential growth of ai and agi
that
he thinks about and the the the threats
of artificial intelligence and all that
kind of ideas like
can you is it jus like can you maybe uh
break apart like
what exactly was so magical to you is it
transformational experience
today everyone knows him for threats and
ai safety um this was pre
that stuff there was i don't think a
mention of ai safety on the page
um this is this is old yukowski stuff
he'd probably denounce it all now he'd
probably be like that's exactly what i
didn't want to happen
sorry man uh
is there something specific you can take
from his work that you can remember
yeah uh it was this realization that
uh computers double in power every 18
months
and humans do not and they haven't
crossed yet
but if you have one thing that's
doubling every 18 months and one thing
that's staying like this
you know here's your log graph here's
your line
you know you calculate that
and that did that open the door to the
exponential thinking
like thinking that like you know what
with technology we can actually
transform the world it opened the door
to human obsolescence
it opened the door to realize that in my
lifetime
humans are going to be replaced
you